Trascrizione: Martina Carlini
Revisore: Denise RQ
Allora buonasera!
Io mi trovo qua in questo
-- non so come chiamarlo --
tempio di bellezza,
con l'ingrato compito invece
di trattare in una maniera, spero,
scientificamente adeguata, una materia
che invece è piuttosto vile, repellente
ed è appunto, è stato già detto,
la corruzione.
Ora, non la corruzione dei corpi,
neanche la corruzione dei frigoriferi
ad opera dei tostapani
di cui ho scoperto l'esistenza oggi,
ma molto più semplicemente
la corruzione delle coscienze,
che è la premessa
perché poi si abbia la corruzione
nella politica, nell'economia
e nell'amministrazione
della cosa pubblica.
Questa è la rappresentazione che ne dà
il Lorenzetti
nel Palazzo Pubblico di Siena:
"L'allegoria del cattivo governo".
E questo è l'identikit
del politico corrotto,
del governante corrotto dell'epoca,
e naturalmente ognuno
vi trovi somiglianze con chi crede.
Penso che ce ne sia più d'una.
Premetto, io proverò a trattare un tema
che inevitabilmente getterà una luce
piuttosto inquietante sul nostro paese.
E allora vorrei esordire
con una nota, per così dire, ottimistica.
Nonostante la corruzione,
o forse proprio grazie alla corruzione,
l'Italia è un paese
di straordinarie opportunità.
E la cosa più incredibile è
que queste opportunità
spesso si presentano
all'insaputa dei beneficiari.
Qualche esempio:
non v'è paese al mondo
in cui qualcuno si trovi pagata
a sua insaputa
una casa con vista Colosseo,
vacanze in un resort da 1000 euro a notte,
ristrutturazioni di ville...
un paese delle meraviglie.
Solamente c'è un anonimo beneficiario,
che non chiede nulla in cambio.
E in questo paese è capito persino
che dei politici in erba,
che poi saranno la futura classe dirigente
di questo paese,
si siano scoperti laureati
in prestigiose università albanesi.
Laureati in tempi record,
a conferma delle loro doti intellettuali,
ma misteriosamente
anch'essi laureati a loro insaputa.
Queste opportunità
non discendono da un colpo di fortuna,
bisogna sapersele meritare.
Occorre una lunga gavetta, lavorare sodo,
di solito lavorare nell'ombra
e soprattutto, trovarsi
nel posto giusto al momento giusto,
avendo intessuto le relazione che contano.
Nella corruzione, è il caso di dirlo,
esiste una meritocrazia
come in pochi altri settori
della vita pubblica italiana.
Purtroppo,è una meritocrazia alla rovescia
che premia inevitabilmente i peggiori,
quelli più abili, nei maneggi sotto banco,
quelli disposti anche a chiudere un occhio
-- e meglio se tutti e due! --
di fronte al disastro collettivo,
che è prodotto appunto dall'azione
di tanti privilegiati a loro insaputa.
E poi c'è da dire che purtroppo
la corruzione miete anche delle vittime
e queste sono vittime
veramente a loro insaputa.
Sono vittime della corruzione
i cittadini che pagano
le opere pubbliche a prezzi esorbitanti,
spesso opere pubbliche inutili
o mal realizzate.
Dietro queste opere pubbliche,
è il caso di dirlo,
ci sono soltanto gli interessi convergenti
dei corrotti e dei corruttori.
In alcuni casi, la corruzione
ha delle vittime ben identificabili,
che hanno un nome e un cognome.
Abbiamo i casi di ammalati che muoiono
perché si sono visti trapiantati
valvole cardiache difettose.
La ragione è che la casa produttrice
ha offerto
la tangente più alta al chirurgo.
Funzionari onesti che sono trucidati
dai sicari mafiosi,
operai soffocati in una cisterna
anche se c'erano stati i controlli
degli ispettori poco tempo prima;
però il controllo era stato pilotato
in cambio di una mazzetta.
Questa è una statica che mostra
come vi sia una correlazione molto forte
tra le morti bianche,
-- le morti sul lavoro --
e i livelli di corruzione
nelle regioni italiane.
Tutti questi esempi, a scanso di equivoci,
sono tratti appunto
dalla cronaca italiana.
Però se ci fermiamo alla superficie,
guardiamo ad esempio
alle statistiche giudiziarie,
la corruzione, miracolosamente in Italia
diventa un problema di poco conto.
Pochi casi e per giunta
che sono in diminuzione negli ultimi anni.
Il fatto è che la corruzione
è un fenomeno che tende a restare oscuro
anzi, io direi, con una citazione colta,
"mirabilmente oscuro",
come Dante Alighieri descrive la bolgia
nel 21 canto dell'Inferno
in cui sono sprofondati
i corrotti dell'epoca,
come vedete, soggettiad una sanzione
un po' più severa di quella prevista
anche nel disegno di legge anticorruzione
di cui oggi si discute.
Corrotti e corruttori
naturalmente operano nell'ombra,
non ci sono testimoni,
e proprio quando non affiora in superficie
la corruzione diventa più pericolosa,
perché si sviluppa appunto
in modo sotterraneo e quindi indisturbato,
non ci si pone il problema
di contrastarla.
Invece, da qualunque parte
la si guardi, o meglio,
se si utilizzano indicatori più efficaci,
la corruzione italiana
rappresenta un'anomalia.
Un'anomalia di un paese
che ha un'economia avanzata,
istituzioni liberal-democratiche,
uno stato di diritto robusto,
ma che nonostante questo presenta
livelli di corruzione percepita,
sulla base dell'indicatore
di Transparency International,
che è il più attendibile in questo senso,
che sono superiori a quelli
in molti paesi in via sviluppo.
Il rosso misura
la febbre della corruzione.
L'Italia è la macchia rossa
in mezzo al Mediterraneo.
Casomai aveste dei dubbi.
Ecco l'Italia è al 69esimo posto
su 182 paesi considerati.
Siamo considerati al pari
del Ghana e della Macedonia,
però più corrotti di Turchia,
Cuba, Namibia, Ruanda,
quartultimi in Europa.
E se dalle percezioni passiamo
alle esperienze concrete,
il quadro non cambia.
Nel 2011 il 12% degli italiani
si è visto chiedere una tangente,
il che è il segno che questo fenomeno
non interessa più,
come dire, grandi appalti,
le grandi speculazioni immobiliari,
ma è entrato ormai nella vita quotidiana
di milioni di nostri concittadini
e presumibilmente anche di molti di noi.
Allora di fronte a questo quadro
un po' allarmante, vorrei dire,
la risposta di chi fa ricerca è,
la speranza della conoscenza.
Se abbiamo delle teorie
che ci aiutano a spiegare le ragioni
di questa diffusione capillare
del fenomeno,
possiamo anche comprendere
com'è che si riproduce
attraverso quali meccanismi,
e magari avere delle idee
che ci possono aiutare a disegnare
degli efficaci strumenti
di prevenzione e di contrasto.
Vediamole queste teorie.
L'approccio economico, che è dominante,
ci dice sostanzialmente
que la corruzione
è presente laddove conviene.
I corrotti e i corruttori potenziali
mettono
su due piatti di una bilancia
i vantaggi e i costi attesi
e decidono se è il caso di proporre
o accettare una tangente.
C'è persino la formula della corruzione,
una specie di formula magica, che ci dice
che la corruzione aumenta
quante più risorse lo stato amministra,
quanto più ampi sono
i poteri discrezionali dei funzionari
e ridotti i controlli sul loro operato
e naturalmente,
la trasparenza della gestione.
Se applichiamo questa formula
della corruzione al caso italiano
si arriva ad una conclusione sconfortante.
Perché in Italia con la corruzione
si può guadagnare molto, anzi moltissimo
e si rischia poco, anzi quasi nulla.
Cominciamo con la prima variabile,
che lega la corruzione
a quanti soldi pubblici
i funzionari spendono,
diciamo infischiandosene
dei prezzi di mercato.
Il caso è quello noto di opere pubbliche,
molte opere pubbliche,
che costano due, tre volte,
nel caso della Tav addirittura,
sei volte tanto per costo al chilometro
di una equivalente realizzazione
in Francia, Spagna e Giappone.
E' il caso del passante ferroviario
di Milano,
che è costato il doppio
di quello di Zurigo
però in compenso abbiamo impiegato
il doppio del tempo nel realizzarlo.
Se si farà la Tav, Torino-Lione,
a mio avviso la prossima
probabile grande mangiatoia di stato,
sarà interessante confrontare
il costo unitario di realizzazione
della stessa galleria che fora
la medesima montagna.
Presumo che ci saranno delle differenze,
va beh, accetto scommesse
su quale sia il versante
sul quale costano di più.
Poi la corruzione è più probabile
quanto più i politici e i funzionari
hanno la possibilità di decidere
discrezionalmente
chi si vede assegnati quei benefici.
Pensiamo alla moltiplicazione
di strutture speciali,
sul modello Protezione Civile,
per intenderci,
che poi si rivelano immancabilmente
presidiate da cricche varie,
comitati d'affari,in cui negli ultimi anni
sono stati affidati,
in deroga ad ogni regola, la gestione
di centinaia, migliaia di appalti,
anche di grande spessore.
In Italia siamo riusciti
a gestire con procedure di emergenza
anche eventi
che erano prevedibili da secoli.
Memorabile il caso
delle celebrazioni "Colombiadi"
che erano attese da almeno 500 anni,
cinque secoli,
e que le opere connesse
a quelle celebrazioni, sono state gestite
come se fossero arrivate
all'improvviso, inattese.
Quindi, con criteri straordinari.
Il problema è che appunto,
come mostra questa slide,
la discrezionalità nasce anche di fatto,
quando un funzionario,
proprio per i ritardi cronici
dei suoi uffici,
può decidere, come dire, discrezionalmente
quale pratica lasciare su un tavolo
a prendere polvere
e quale invece accelerare.
Quindi qui la corruzione,
l'inefficienza della macchina burocratica
si sposano a meraviglia.
E qui lo vediamo:
una correlazione fortissima
tra inefficienza burocratica e corruzione
nei paesi dell'unione europea.
E da ultimo, naturalmente,
la corruzione aumenta
quanto meno efficaci sono i controlli,
tutti i tipi di controllo,
non solo quelli penali
a cui siamo abituati a pensare,
ma anche quelli amministrativi,
contabili, sociali e politici.
E allora, non c'è da sorprendersi
se domina una sensazione
per così dire da liberi tutti.
I magistrati parlano
di una sindrome da impunità,
che sembra affliggerei protagonisti
delle vicende di corruzione.
Perché di fatto, a ben guardare,
la corruzione in Italia
è praticamente depenalizzata.
Abbiamo 12% di tangenti pagate;
vuol dire almeno 4 o 5 milioni
di episodi di corruzione,
ma a questo si accompagna
a livello di procedimenti penali,
circa 1000 persone denunciate
e all'incirca, il dato lo mostra,
300 persone condannate ogni anno.
Di queste 300 persone condannate,
l'1,8% rischia di scontare
un solo giorno di carcere.
Quindi, una vicenda che porta molto
probabilmente circa metà o due terzi
dei procedimenti penali
a finire in prescrizione:
quindi in nulla di fatto.
Ma, non solo, i funzionari corrotti
non vengono licenziati,
ma spesso fanno carriera proprio,
perché hanno informazioni ricattatorie
da utilizzare per non rivelare
le malefatte altrui.
I politici di norma sono ricandidati
dai loro pariti e rieletti.
In Parlamento oggi ne abbiamo
circa il 10% di pregiudicati
o imputati di vari reati.
Non si parli di stigma
o di riprovazione sociale,
di danni alla reputazione
che dovrebbero derivare dal coinvolgimento
in questo tipo di vicende,
meno che mai per gli imprenditori
che su queste vicende sembrano vivere
una sorta di limbo morale.
Allora altra variabile,
per quanto sia conveniente economicamente
non è detto che tutti
siano pronti a entrare
in questo universo della corruzione
contano anche altre variabili,
le variabili diciamo di ordine culturale,
il tipo di valori che, come dire,
improntano le scelte
dei funzionari e dei cittadini.
Ecco ci sono altri modelli di analisi
però purtroppo,
che si concentrano su questi fattori,
ma purtroppo anche guardando
alla corruzione in questa prospettiva,
il caso italiano spicca
come un caso anomalo.
E' studiando l'Italia
che un famoso sociologo
ha coniato il termine
di "familismo morale",
per descrivere proprio una struttura
di valori prevalente nella società
che porta a massimizzare la ricerca
del vantaggio materiale, immediato
per sè e per la propria
cerchia familiare ristretta.
Accompagnato dalla sfiducia verso chiunque
dichiari di perseguire
un interesse generale.
Ora potrà suscitare qualche sospetto
riguardo al familismo morale
che il mio cognome,Vannucci, sia lo stesso
del presentatore di questa giornata.
Vi lascio col dubbio,
se vi sia un qualche nesso,
un qualche legame
che non sia la mera coincidenza.
Appunto, molti altri studi
poi convergono nel sottolineare
che insomma questa debolezza
del senso civico
caratterizza ampie fasce
della società italiana
e in qualche modo pone deboli barriere
al loro coinvolgimento nella corruzione.
Questo potrebbe forse bastare
a spiegare l'anomalia italiana,
ma c'è anche di peggio.
Nella mia ricerca,
nel mio lavoro di ricerca
ho guardato in particolare a meccanismi
di regolazione interna della corruzione;
cioè, lo studio del caso italiano
ci mostra proprio
come la corruzione possa
a certe condizioni colonizzare
del tutto alcuni centri di spesa pubblica,
diventa, per così dire, il motore
della vita politica e amministrativa.
E allora in questo universo
della corruzione sistemica
entrano in vigore regole
che sono alternative
rispetto a quelle dello stato
e che dettano ai protagonisti
della corruzione,
la gamma di condotte accettabili:
a chi rivolgersi, quanto pagare, cosa dire
e naturalmente anche cosa tacere,
come scongiurare inconvenienti,
come emarginare e punire
chi non sta al gioco
e naturalmente come calcolare
e ripartire le tangenti.
E spesso addirittura esiste anche
un governo della corruzione.
Cioè ci sono soggetti che scendono
in campo in questo mercato illegale,
per garantire che le regole vengano
rispettate e punire chi non sta al gioco.
Questi soggetti sono diversi
in alcuni casi sono leader politici,
faccendieri dei contatti trasversali,
imprenditori, alti dirigenti ministeriali
e spesso anche capofamiglia mafiosi.
Come mostra questo atlante
della corruzione europea,
le regioni che conoscono un radicamento
delle organizzazioni criminali in Italia,
le quattro regioni meridionali,
sono quelle che conoscono
i più alti livelli di corruzione.
Vado alle conclusioni.
Un grande studioso della democrazia,
de Tocqueville ha scritto,
que non dobbiamo temere
l'immoralità dei grandi,
ma piuttosto la vista dell'immoralità
che conduce alla grandezza.
E allora persino i 60 miliardi
di euro annui di costo
che sono stimati dalla Corte dei Conti,
e che tutti citano, diventano poca cosa
di fronte allo spettacolo
di una classe dirigente
che ha fatto delle risorse ricavate
dalla corruzione la chiave per la scalata
nella loro carriera politica,
amministrativa e imprenditoriale.
Mentre quelli che dicevano di no
venivano sistematicamente emarginati,
costretti al silenzio o alla fuga.
E allora non perdiamo le speranze,
in fondo il 21 dicembre di quest'anno
il mondo finirà no?
Quindi magari finirà anche questo universo
repellente della corruzione.
Però se interveniamo sugli stessi fattori
che spiegano la corruzione italiana
e il suo radicamento,
possiamo anche modificarla
in profondità questa realtà.
Ad esempio dobbiamo capire
che la propensione alla corruzione
non è inscritta nel patrimonio genetico.
La Svezia, i paesi scandinavi erano paesi
che conoscevano una corruzione capillare
fino alla fine dell' '800.
E altri paesi, Singapore, Hong Kong
fino alla metà degli anni '70 del '900
erano paesi estremamente corrotti,
ma adeso tutti questi paesi
sono ai vertici
delle classifiche dell'integrità.
Perché?
Perché son state approvate e applicate
riforme radicali, buone leggi
che hanno favorito
trasparenza e responsabilità
dei governanti da un lato,
partecipazione e coinvolgimento
dei cittadini dall'altro.
E lentamente in quei paesi è mutata
anche la struttura sottostante
dei valori sociali sono cambiati
i modelli culturali che spingono
all'onestà funzionari e cittadini.
E allora per disinnescare i meccanismi
della corruzione sistemica
che caratterizza l'Italia,
non è necessario attendere l'intervento
dall'alto, salvifico del legislatore,
che da troppo tempo sta
lì a tergiversare con una legge
che è un brodino annacquato tra l'altro
con dentro molti bocconi avvelenati.
La classe politica italiana
su questo versante,
è omertosa, inadempiente,
per usare un eufemismo
da almeno vent'anni.
C'è un ritardo che non potrà colmare
in poco tempo.
E allora per tutti i cittadini
di buona volontà,
forse è il caso di cominciare a pensare
a politiche e strumenti
di prevenzione della corruzione
che nascano dal basso.
Ci sono esperienze straordinarie
in questo campo:
le campagne avviate
da Libera e don Ciotti,
il codice etico promosso
da Avviso Pubblico,
un'associazione di enti locali
contro le mafie,
che è stato già adottato da decline
di sindaci e amministratori e assessori.
E allora per dare slancio
a questa campagna,
e questa politica
anticorruzione dal basso,
qui la speranza per il futuro, il ruolo
delle giovani generazioni è decisivo,
perché la corruzione, è stato già detto,
deruba soprattutto loro, spoglia i giovani
della speranza di un'ascesa sociale
e professionale fondata sui loro meriti.
Costringe spesso alla emigrazione,
non solo a fuggire
sono i cervelli e i corpi,
ma spesso anche le coscienze.
C'è un dato inquietante
col quale possiamo chiudere:
la correlazione fortissima che esiste
tra i livelli di corruzione
nei paesi europei
e la scarsa propensione delle imprese
a investire nell'innovazione,
nel cambiamento, nella ricerca.
Allora sono convinto che le barriere
più forti alla corruzione italiana
non possano nascere in parlamento.
Quelle barriere devono consolidarsi credo
all'interno della società civile.
Attraverso i valori
che ci trasmettiamo l'un l'altro,
esprimendo i nostri giudizi morali
e col nostro esempio quotidiano,
perché in fondo il valore di quello
che possiamo ricavare dalle nostre azioni
non é misurabile soltanto
in termini monetari:
un euro guadagnato
impiegando le proprie capacità,
per produrre beni
e servizi utili agli altri
non ha lo stesso valore di un euro
che invece viene ottenuto
trafficando nell'ombra,
pagando tangenti
e depredando il bene comune.
Se riusciamo a far diventare
questo elementare messaggio,
vorrei dire di coscienza civile,
un patrimonio comune,
quale che sia il nostro ruolo sociale
o il nostro credo politico,
persino la lotta alla corruzione italiana
non è senza speranza
e potremo aspirare a vivere
come nell'allegoria del Lorenzetti,
nel paradiso del buon governo.
Grazie!
(Aplausi)